[Musique]
le département de la réunion et le
sidelec syndicat intercommunal
d'électricité de la réunion signent
conjointement une convention pour
renforcer leurs actions de lutte contre
le changement climatique
le département s'engage à développer ses
plans de maîtrise énergétique et baissé
ainsi sa consommation globale de 20 à
30%
jusqu'à maintenant les stades on a
installé des panneaux photovoltaïques
sur les collèges donc c'est un premier
point nous avons travaillé aussi sur
l'utilisation des énergies
hydroélectrique sur le réseau
d'irrigation
nous participons auprès de maurice
gironcel donc au financement de la
marque bellemans ce qu'il organisait le
climat protéger la biodiversité et
limiter l'empreinte carbone sur notre
territoire
un défi que doit relever toutes les
collectivités pour une politique
équitable de transition énergétique
il faut développer nos ressources et
maîtriser nos besoins il faut
effectivement développer le solaire pour
plus il faut développer l'éolien encore
plus nous avons porté l'expérience au
niveau de cette zone que c'est faisable
il faut développer également biogaz et
il faut également et bien sûr économiser
l'énergie
mais il faut aussi développer le bio la
biomasse on sait que d'ici 2025 2030 on
ne pourra plus importer du charbon on ne
pourra plus brûler du feu lourd
maîtrisée nous énergies renouvelables
favoriser les circuits de distribution
courts développer la production locale
et diminuer nos besoins en énergie
tels sont les défis à venir pour faire
de la réunion une île autonome en
énergie d'ici 2030
[Musique]